Vous pouvez sans doute imaginer quelques options, comme boire un verre,
écrire un courrier, ou dormir pendant cette conférence ennuyeuse.
Si vous osez...
Mais pas d'envisager toutes les options.
Pensez à une invasion extraterrestre, ici-même, à Milan,
ou moi -- j'ai arrêté de penser pendant 15 minutes.
C'est vraiment compliqué de concevoir un tel espace,
mais en fait, nous avons une excuse.
Ce n'est pas si facile d'imaginer cet espace
parce que nous essayons de concevoir un évènement à partir du néant,
de quelque chose qui n'est jamais arrivé, et pour lequel nous n'avons aucun indice.
Une solution typique pourrait être la suivante :
observer le futur avec les yeux du passé,
en se fiant sur tous les évènements passés dans le temps
et en espérant que ce sera suffisant pour prédire l'avenir.
Mais nous savons que ça ne fonctionne pas.
La première météo, par exemple, est fondée sur ce principe, mais elle s'est trompée.
Ça n'a pas marché à cause de la grande complexité
du phénomène sous jacent.
Aujourd'hui, nous savons que la prédiction doit être basée sur la modélisation,
c'est à dire en créant un modèle synthétique du système,
en lui faisant faire des simulations
et ensuite en projetant le système dans le futur, grâce au modèle.
Aujourd'hui nous pouvons faire ça pour de nombreux cas,
à l'aide de nombreuses données.
Observer le futur avec les yeux du passé
pourrait être trompeur pour les machines aussi.
Pensez-y un moment.
Imaginez-vous un instant au milieu des terres australiennes
Vous attendez, sous le soleil.
Et quelque chose d'étrange survient.
Une voiture s'arrête brusquement
très, très loin d'un kangourou traversant la route.
Vous regardez de plus près
et vous réalisez qu'il n'y a personne dans la voiture.
Elle ne redémarre pas, même après que le kangourou soit parti.
Pour diverses raisons,
les algorithmes conduisant la voiture ne peuvent pas appréhender
cette bête étrange sautant ici et là sur la route.
Alors, la voiture s'arrête.
C'est une histoire vraie, en fait.
C'est arrivé il y a quelques mois à un véhicule en conduite automatique de Volvo,
au fin fond de l'Australie.
(Rires)
C'est un problème général.
Je pense que dans un futur proche, ça touchera de plus en plus
l'intelligence artificielle et l'apprentissage automatique.
C'est aussi un très vieux problème, je dirais du 17ème siècle.
Mais aujourd'hui,
nous avons de nouveaux outils et de nouvelles pistes pour les résoudre.
Revenons en arrière,
5 ans plus tôt.
L'Italie. Rome en hiver.
L'hiver de 2012 à Rome fut vraiment particulier.
Rome fut le témoin d'une des plus grandes chutes de neige de son histoire.
Cet hiver fut aussi particulier pour mes collègues et moi,
car nous avons eu l'intuition que le schéma mathématique du possible --
je répète, le schéma mathématique du possible, du possible --
pourraient contribuer à créer l'apparition du nouveau.
Je me souviens de ce jour parce qu'il neigeait.
À cause de la neige, nous étions bloqués, retenus dans mon service,
sans espoir de rentrer à la maison.
Du coup, nous nous sommes resservis un café, tranquillement,
et nous avons continué à discuter.
À un moment -- peut-être pas à ce jour de neige précisément --
mais à un moment, nous avons fait le lien
entre le problème du nouveau
et un merveilleux concept proposé il y a des années
par Stuart Kauffman : le possible adjacent.
Le possible adjacent repose sur toutes ces choses.
Ça pourrait être des idées, des molécules, ou des produits technologiques
qui ne sont qu'à un pas
de ce qui existe déjà,
et que l'on peut atteindre via des modifications incrémentales
et des reconstitutions progressives du matériel existant.
Pour prendre un exemple, si j'évoque l'espace de mes amis,
mon possible adjacent serait le groupe d'amis de mes amis
qui ne sont pas encore mes amis.
J'espère que c'est clair.
Si je rencontre une nouvelle personne, disons Briar,
tous ces amis rentreraient aussitôt dans mon possible adjacent,
et en repousseraient les limites.
Du point de vue mathématique --
et je n'ai aucun doute que c'est ce que vous voulez envisager,
vous pouvez regarder cette image.
Supposons que ceci est votre univers.
Je sais, j'en demande beaucoup.
Donc, ceci est votre univers. Vous êtes le point rouge.
Et le point vert est votre possible adjacent,
quelque chose que vous n'avez jamais côtoyé.
Vous vivez votre vie.
Vous bougez. Vous bougez dans l'espace.
Vous prenez un verre, voyez des amis ou lisez un livre.
A un moment, vous arrivez au point vert :
Vous rencontrez Briar pour la première fois.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Il se passe qu'il y a un nouvel élément,
un élément tout neuf de l'espace,
qui devient possible pour vous à ce moment précis,
sans que vous ayez la moindre possibilité de prévoir cela
avant d'arriver à ce point.
Au delà, se développe un énorme groupe de points
qui pourront devenir des possibles ultérieurement.
Vous voyez combien l'espace du possible est très particulier,
parce qu'il n'est pas prédéfini.
Nous ne pouvons pas l'anticiper.
C'est quelque chose de continuellement modelé et remanié
par nos actions et nos choix.
Nous étions si fascinés par les liens que nous étions en train de faire --
les scientifiques sont comme ça --
qu'à partir de cela,
nous avons conçu notre formule mathématique pour le possible adjacent,
20 ans après la proposition initiale de Kauffman.
Notre théorie -- c'est un point clé --
est fondée de manière cruciale sur l'interaction complexe
entre la manière avec laquelle l'espace du possible se diffuse
et se restructure,
et notre méthode d’exploration.
Après notre épiphanie de 2012,
nous sommes remis au travail, car nous devions développer cette théorie.
Nous avons développé un certain nombre de prédictions
à tester dans la vraie vie.
Nous avons évidemment besoin d'un procédé d'évaluation
pour étudier l'innovation.
Parcourons d’abord ensemble quelques-unes de nos prédictions.
La première concerne le rythme d'innovation,
le taux d'occurence des nouveautés dans des systèmes très différents.
Notre théorie prédit que le taux d'innovation
suit en principe une courbe universelle, comme celle-ci.
C'est le taux d'innovation dans le temps, dans différentes conditions.
Curieusement, nous prédisons que le taux d'innovation
décroît régulièrement au fil du temps
Donc, l'innovation devient de plus en plus difficile
au fur et à mesure du progrès dans le temps.
C'est net. C'est intéressant. C'est beau. Nous étions ravis.
Mais la vraie question est : est-ce exact ?
Nous devions évidemment confronter nos prédictions à la réalité.
Nous sommes donc redescendus sur Terre,
et nous avons collecté beaucoup de données, des téraoctets de données,
poursuivant l'innovation dans Wikipédia, Twitter,
dans la manière d'écrire des logiciels gratuits,
même la façon dont nous écoutons la musique.
Je ne peux vous dire à quel point nous étions ébahis, heureux et excités
de découvrir que nos prédictions théorique se vérifiaient dans des systèmes réels,
dans plusieurs différents systèmes réels.
Nous étions très enthousiastes.
Apparemment, nous semblions être sur la bonne voie.
et bien sûr, nous ne pouvions pas nous arrêter là.
Nous ne nous sommes pas arrêté.
On a donc continué.
À un moment, nous avons fait une nouvelle découverte.
On l'a surnommée : « Les nouveautés corrélées. »
C'est très simple.
Nous en faisons tous l'expérience.
Imaginez que vous écoutez « Suzanne » de Leonard Cohen.
Cela déclenche en vous une passion pour Cohen.
Du coup, vous commencez à écouter frénétiquement toute son œuvre.
Et puis, vous réalisez que Fabrizio De André
a enregistré une version italienne de « Suzanne », etc.
Curieusement,
la notion de possible adjacent comprend déjà la croyance commune
qu'un chose mène à une autre,
dans différents systèmes.
Mais la raison pour laquelle nous sommes excités
est que nous pouvions enfin étayer cette intuition
avec de la substance scientifique pour la première fois
et commencer à faire des prévisions sur la manière dont le nouveau survient.
Donc, les nouveautés sont en corrélation.
Elles n'arrivent pas par hasard.
C'est une bonne nouvelle
car ça implique que des missions impossibles
ne soient pas si impossibles après tout,
si nous nous laissons guider par notre intuition,
qui d'une certaine manière nous amène à une réaction en chaîne positive.
Mais il y a une troisième conséquence de l'existence du possible adjacent
que nous avons appelée : « vagues de nouveautés ».
Pour simplifier, en musique, sans vagues de nouveautés,
nous serions toujours en train d'écouter Mozart ou Beethoven,
ce qui est super,
mais pas tout le temps.
Nous écoutons aussi Pet Shop Boys ou Justin Bieber.
Enfin, certains parmi nous.
(Rires)
Nous pouvions donc discerner clairement tous ces motifs
dans l'énorme quantité de données que nous avions collectées et analysées.
Par exemple, nous avons découvert
que les succès en musique naissent continuellement, vous le saviez,
et ensuite disparaissent pour laisser place aux intemporels.
Donc les vagues de nouveautés vont et viennent
tandis que la marée retient toujours les classiques.
Les intemporels coexistent avec les nouveaux hits.
Notre théorie ne prédit pas seulement ces vagues de nouveautés.
Ce serait sans intérêt.
Mais elle explique aussi pourquoi elles existent,
et qu'elles sont là pour une raison particulière :
parce qu'en tant qu'humains, nous déployons diverses stratégies
dans l'espace du possible.
Certains d'entre nous ont tendance à suivre les sentiers battus.
Nous disons d'eux qu'ils exploitent.
D'autres se lancent toujours dans de nouvelles aventures.
Nous disons d'eux qu'ils explorent.
Et nous avons découvert que tous les systèmes que nous avons évalués
sont exactement à la frontière entre ces deux stratégies,
environ 80% d'exploitation et 20% d'exploration,
un peu comme les blade runners de l'innovation.
Il semble donc que le bon équilibre, qu’on pourrait qualifier de raisonnable,
entre le passé et le futur, entre l'exploitation et l'exploration,
est déjà en place, ou peut être nécessaire dans notre système.
J'insiste, la bonne nouvelle est que nous avons les outils scientifiques
pour investiguer cet équilibre,
peut-être le poussant plus loin dans un avenir proche.
Donc comme vous pouvez l'imaginer,
j'étais complètement fasciné par tout ça.
Notre schéma mathématique fournit déjà des signaux et des indices
pour investiguer l'espace du possible
et sur la méthode dont nous le créons et l'explorons.
Il y a encore plus.
Ceci, j'imagine, est le point de départ de quelque chose qui a le potentiel
pour devenir un merveilleux voyage de recherche scientifique sur le nouveau.
J'ajouterai que c'est aussi une quête personnelle.
Je pense que ça peut avoir beaucoup de retombées
et un énorme impact dans des activités cruciales
telles que l'apprentissage, l'éducation, la recherche ou les affaires.
Si par exemple, vous pensez à l'intelligence artificielle,
on va devoir s’appuyer dans l'avenir proche,
de plus en plus sur la structure du possible adjacent,
pour la restructurer, la modifier,
et aussi pour lutter contre l'inconnu que nous reserve l’avenir.
En parallèle, nous avons plein de nouveaux outils
pour rechercher comment la créativité fonctionne
et ce qui provoque l'innovation.
Le but de tout ça est d'éduquer une génération de personnes
capables d'avoir de nouvelles idées pour faire face aux défis à venir.
Nous savons tous.
Je pense que c'est un long chemin à parcourir,
mais les questions, et les outils,
sont maintenant là, adjacent et possible.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)